when we met Indian student jatas Kumar
vaswani his singular focus on school was
such that he had yet to buy furniture
only reason why I want an apartment as a
student is that I just want to sleep
money is also an issue International
students like vaswani pay roughly five
times regular tuition rates which has
been critical for many Canadian schools
facing budget shortfalls but over the
past few years foreign student numbers
have grown so quickly they now outnumber
Canadians at 10 of Ontario's 24 publicly
funded colleges Koga and Centennial
College uh two colleges in Southern
Ontario combined over that 16-month
period brought in more International
students and had more uh student visas
issued than Canada's 15 uh research
universities combined do you feel like
you're actually in Canada at
school uh I would say uh no more than
any other school in Canada Koga has
benefited from recruiting
internationally 30,000 or 71% of its
42,000 students come from overseas
leading to a budget surplus last year of
$106 million putting a cap on new
students coming to this country would
essentially turn off that profit
pipeline in an email a conastoga
spokesperson said we need to ensure we
protect Ontario's reputation as a
leading destination for international
students and if the rule change it's
essential we get this
right that's true for a number of
reasons the housing marketing Kitchener
which has seen low vacancy rates and
increasingly High rents has become a
serious
problem and the students themselves
worry they're being made into scapegoats
baswani had expected a work permit when
he graduates this spring it's unclear
under the new rules if that will still
happen that's what I have understood
since the beginning when I come here you
have to it's just up to you like so many
other new Canadians all he wants is an
opportunity but it might be out of his
control Mike drite Global News kitner
waterl Ontario